So two weeks ago, I did a story asking, is
the United States a failed state?
We failed on a medical response to the pandemic.
Health systems falling apart, corruption,
no trust in government.
Are we a failed state?
We are now finding ourselves asking, is the
U.S. a first world country in light of the
completely absent leadership as federal from
federal government?
As protests rage nationally over out-of-control
policing as it is seen by millions and millions
of people, and in addition to the protests,
literal dumpster fires around the White House
as the White House sits in darkness with Trump
tweeting as you have violence, police attacking
protesters, protesters attacking police, we're
seeing media get shot with rubber bullets
and attacked not just physically but ideologically
for their presence at the unrest.
Caitlin Rust, a reporter for an NBC affiliate
station in Louisville, Kentucky, was fired
upon by police Friday night covering alive
street protests that was going on CNN report.
Reporter Omar Hammen is was arrested while
covering protests over the weekend.
Subsequently released.
It was chalked up to confusion by police about
who he was.
He happens to be black.
Last night, Cleveland police said no media
would be allowed in any of the downtown area
as protests raged.
It's not even clear that that's legal to do.
This concept of a first world country comes
from the Cold War.
It has some implicit biases.
But really now what we're talking about is
the Westernize developed nations of the world.
So look at what we have.
Corrupt, incompetent leadership.
Increasing attacks on media by government
and by police.
Growing unrest between police and the public.
A judiciary system that has two tiers, one
for the rich and one for the poor.
We've got rampant cronyism and corruption,
lack of access to quality health care for
a huge portion of the country, a failing education
system.
Our response to the corona virus pandemic
has completely failed compared to other developed
nations.
Infrastructure is not crumbling, but we are
way behind where we should be for a country
of our wealth.
Look at our airports to some around the world.
Look at our highways to those in many parts
of the world.
And meanwhile, our president is sitting in
a white and darkened White House, sometimes
in the bunker below it.
On Friday night, as D.C. literally burns,
providing no leadership, no words of de-escalation,
nothing other than self aggrandizement and
threats to protesters.
So I'm not literally saying we are no longer
a first world country, but more and more we're
reacting to events the way a less advanced
country would.
I want to hear from you about this.
I will have more about it upcoming.
Let me know your thoughts on Twitter at David
Pakman.
Remember to make sure you are subscribed for
free to the daily one hour long David Pakman
show podcast on whatever podcasting app you
use.